my god this is such a mess ladies and
gentlemen cyberpunk oh you see that
cable ever sighs oh man I'm so stuck we
got a whole year waiting for cyber fog
that I've loose over that gameplay video
[Applause]
hey guys what's up welcome back to
potato mode where we take the best
looking games we know and turn them into
mush my name is Joey here with Rob
handler II hi on here we're here every
Friday with a new PC game to turn inside
out so if you got suggestion for us on
the game that you'd like to see comment
on it below and this week as you can see
we have somewhat of a crisis on our
hands if you've seen potato mode you
knew that we're gonna take this game
make it look as good as we can and then
just try to make a look as worse as we
can so the game looks the game looks
pretty damn good dude it looks really
good for 11 years like you would not if
you showed someone this thing you would
never have guessed this is a decade old
game so let's take this view in mm-hmm
cuz it's about to go bye-bye oh really
all right so we are going to just real
quickly take a look at the game or the
system settings you're gonna go into
graphics and we are gonna go just turn
everything off we just go all the way
down for everything so until advanced
hello apply warning warning these are
really low warning all right what a
lovely looking game and got here so
mostly I feel like most of the time when
we we've done this so far the low
settings have been pretty pretty
comparable to the high settings not here
not here this is this is about as low as
you're getting as bad as you can make it
look within the game
eleven years ago this be like yeah this
is doable here's like eleven years ago
this looks pretty good Ryan
so we've seen the game on the highest
settings as well as as you can see right
here its lowest settings and we are
gonna go a little bit further than that
so what you're seeing right here are two
windows on the left are my own config
files that I've graciously inputted some
some weird looking stuff into and on the
right is the crisis just a regular game
folder right here mhm and so what I'm
gonna do is drag this first one in here
and within here there's a bunch of stuff
that does a lot of weird stuff to the
graphics and you're about to see exactly
what that is right now alright so as you
can see we're also in dev mode so you
can see some a little bit of the stats
in the upper right hand corner your
framerate looks pretty solid I know it's
a steady 999 all right so I'm gonna give
the the reins back to you Rob oh thank
you so much okay should I engage yes
please
crisis alert crisis alert Wow
what oh my god
I guess you could say this is a skybox
oh it's a distance scaling yeah oh my
god oh god Wow yeah this this is a
freaking need so I'm gonna do a couple
things to help us out let's get custom
console commands in here there's so much
going on alright so we are now going a
little bit faster I think this will help
us and are accomplishing our goals in
the showing off more of the game alright
so we can we can kind of view the island
from up here kind of see all the
terrible things I've done to the to the
trees and the grass keep a low profile
oh my god I needs guns when you can just
run into people at like a thousand miles
an hour do more of that
this would be scary my god we'll never
be able to catch me down like whoa dude
is a cyberpunk ladies and gentlemen
cyberpunk world premiere
[Applause]
[Music]
yo you see oh man I watched that video
like 40 times I can't I'm so stuck we
got a whole year waiting for cyber [ __ ]
man I've moved over that gameplay video
[Laughter]
so sick I'm realizing now that this main
may have been V Wars introduction for a
game either of us neither of us have
played very much of this level designs
kind of boring looking at the same
cinematic okay now we're talking what
are you doing that watching your camera
feed that was that was good stuff good
moves oh there's a there's a third
person there's a third and a fourth
somewhere there to begin with you greet
the game you skip so much oh my god how
are you losing framerate well who knows
why just goes to show you even even
having it in potato mode our computer
still can't run Crysis we were rocking a
good at 15 their team frames-per-second
up oh man dude this game does not hold
up oh you know what we might need to do
here I'm gonna save it real quick right
here and we'll do a couple more changes
a couple modifications here the they
have to do with the trees and all OH
okay cuz the trees we're looking pretty
good yeah so we gotta mess with them
more alright there we go get rid of
those damn trees Oh
a lot of people talk to you now all
right I think I just need a rocket
launcher that's all look at my site
that's supposed to be a laser right
there oh yeah you're right too much okay
I got requests big guy in the toilet
pump pick a guy up and just like climb
2,000 feet and drop them hmm
yes yes yes yes yes uh-huh this is good
this is all good those glass eyes he's
very calm it's very peaceful up here yes
[Laughter]
let's see how this looks back on tinny
because we've had a rat 600 or 800 by
600 so far oh now this game looks good
this still doesn't seem good enough I
think it's still a lot of textures left
over so we can do one last thing okay so
we're gonna modify a couple of values
here I was gonna say that yeah same one
that's er same 1f0
what'd you do Oh
so we can actually fly wherever we want
on the island even though it says will
be terminated can't die so many cues
we're hitting where are you
oh he's flying to the other side he was
the beginning the game I understand
scramble scramble while we're playing
there's a guy Beckett a TA trying to
write down everything is going on cue
the invasion of aliens at the wood
that's act 3 I know just so was there
anything so we can go to check out some
nice-looking faces that's what I want to
see was that our truck oh this is toilet
Barnea enough punching up doors in the
last episode be very very gentle let's
bring them to the top of the mountain
okay I think we need a human sacrifice
it's a fantastic idea you just throw
them straight down okay
wait help Oh farmer we were so far away
that's so funny
get up get up play with us yes yes damn
awesome you should just be a speck right
like I'll be here well there you go guys
that was Crysis 1 a potato mode hmm if
you guys have a game that you'd like to
see this done too I don't know why you
would ever want that to happen to your
favorite game but if you'd like to see
it happen just leave in the comments
below you can tweet at us
we'll try to make it happen I know a lot
of guys have been suggesting ps4 games
and that's a little bit more difficult
since it is playstation and love the
graphics options that you've been seeing
how are only capable on PC but we'll
keep it in mind in case something
amazing happens later on oh my god his
eyes but again thank you guys for
watching we'll be back again every
Friday with another PC game potato fide
so we'll see you then
obviously you've never seen the engine
crisis where they revealed you've just
been living in The Truman Show the
entire time is about to say true in show
dang it
it's absolutely that it's like the alpha
version of Truman Show
so can we run out these edges Truman he
knows that
[Music]